ideas never translate automatically into
political action they have to be
embodied in persons
[Music]
by the late 1970s the structure of a
conservative alternative to elements of
democratic orthodoxy were clearly
emerging around certain principles of
smaller government with lower taxes a
relatively free economy with a minimum
of regulation
in opposition to communism on all of
these points and more
the burgeoning movement found a winning
spokesman in ronald reagan whose
presidential time
had it last come in 1980 after several
previous attempts
but reagan was more than just a vehicle
for other people's ideas ideas never
translate automatically into political
action they have to be embodied
in persons
and reagan's persona gave a particular
cast to the ideas that he propounded he
was a superbly gifted speaker who had
experiences as a movie actor and a
television performer he was uh entering
into a television age he was the master
of mr president i want to raise an issue
that i think has been lurking out there
for two or three weeks and cast it
specifically in national security terms
you already are the oldest president in
history and some of your staff say you
were tired after your most recent
encounter with mr mr uh mondale
um
i recall yet that president kennedy had
to go for days on end with very little
sleep during the cuba missile crisis is
there any doubt in your mind that you
would be able to function in such
circumstances
not at all mr truett and i and i want
you to know that also i will not make
age an issue of this campaign i am not
going to exploit for
political purposes
my opponents youth and inexperience
[Applause]
he had to run against jimmy carter
carter was no match for reagan uh in the
1980 campaign and not only because
carter's record in office had been so
poor and so difficult to defend
reagan offered a vision
that was more hopeful than carter's in
his inauguration address that day reagan
blamed government itself for many of the
nation's problems and proposed that a
more open less heavily regulated less
heavily taxed economy
would produce growth
the other principal goal of gregan was
to rebuild the nation's standing in the
world
after the humiliations of vietnam
and iran
and
waging the cold war with the soviet
union required a more effective and
decisive
american policy as he said once mice
here's my strategy on the cold war
we win
and they lose
that view never changed all the details
filled themselves out in different ways
the soviet union
was an evil empire it was the focus of
evil in the modern world he land-based
and blocked communism for its many
failures its cruelty its inefficiency
its disdain for human rights
it's incompetence it's atheism
he increased spending on defense
put into production a variety of uh new
defense system the b-1 bomber the mx
land-based missile he built the 600-ship
american navy
and most intriguing of all he started
work on what was called the strategic
defense initiative or sdi
which critics called star wars because
it used lasers and particle beams to
shoot down incoming enemy missiles the
critics said it wouldn't work and
even if it did work it would only fuel
another round of the arms race this time
in space
the euro missile crisis as it was called
was a turning point
and in the soviet union the ascent of
mikhail gorbachev as party secretary
general secretary of the communist party
um there began a
conspicuous change in tone
of soviet leadership gorbachev wanted to
reform soviet life he wanted to open it
up he wanted to restructure it reagan
grasped the opportunities presented by
this change in power worked with
gorbachev favorably uh although he was
he was insistent that words be followed
by deeds when he spoke at the
brandenburg gate
in west berlin
at the berlin wall
general secretary gorbachev
if you seek peace
if you seek prosperity for the soviet
union in eastern europe
if you seek
liberalization come here to this gate
mr gorbachev
open this gate
mr gorbachev
[Applause]
mr gorbachev
tear down this wall
[Applause]
of course garbage gorbachev did not
oblige him in this regard but he did
negotiate
a treaty to
abolish intermediate-range
uh nuclear missiles
first time the two nations had agreed to
eliminate an entire class of weapons a
move that would have been unthinkable
without reagan's firmness in the euro
missile crisis
thank you for watching
we hope you're enjoying our highlight
series and invite you to explore all of
hillsdale college's online courses they
are free and for everyone who loves to
learn